my name is Meredith and I'm very pleased
thank you for the introduction pleased
to be here I'm going to be talking about
anvil which is a platform for building
web apps with nothing but Python and
before I get into the nitty-gritty of
how it works you might want to ask like
why why is this a thing we want to do
and I will argue to you that the way we
build web apps today most of the time is
pretty broken right just think about it
from the point of view of your data
right your data probably starts as rows
in a database table in typical web app
you access it via SQL you then read
those from a database turn them into
objects on your server
probably in Python in present company
and they have methods and attributes to
access them but then you of course you
don't leave them as objects you
immediately turn them into JSON and send
them over rest with over HTTP with this
very limited set of verbs get post put
delete and so on and then the other end
of that HTTP connection is some
JavaScript which is going to reassemble
that into objects at different objects
in a different programming language with
methods and attributes on their own and
then we have to transform that into HTML
Dom for the browser to render and then
will you CSS to turn that into pixels
and that is a lot of different
representations of your data and there's
a lot of transformation levels there and
all those transformations are tedious
and repetitive and what's worse than
being tedious or repetitive
is that they attract the wrong kind of
magic what do I mean by the wrong kind
of magic I'm going to illustrate but I
take your totally unfair potshot at SQL
alchemy who in this room has used SQL
alchemy yeah ok right for those of you
who haven't it's a library for
representing rows in an SQL database as
Python objects and this is an unfair
potshot because this is actually really
cool it lets you write expressions like
this right filter book top price is less
than 20 that's nice but of course
transforming that Python expression into
SQL you can run against a database is
black magic we are talking metaclasses
we are talking or overloading ordinary
Python operators to do something
completely different to what they know
do if you think that's a numerical
comparison you're in for a surprise that
is generating source code in a different
programming language and that's okay if
you do it once but if you have this
level of magic every layer of this stack
you are going to have a bad day and of
course that's exactly what we do right
we have ORM s like SQL alchemy turning
database rows into objects we have rest
frameworks helping us represent those
objects over HTTP and JSON we have
JavaScript frameworks like angular SRI
sources turning those HTTP requests back
into objects we have templating engines
to turn those objects into HTML Dom we
have CSS frameworks to turn those things
into pixels and every layer of those is
the wrong sort of magic it abuses the
semantics of one layer to represent an
adjacent layer you need to learn it all
and it is brittle I mean we're Python
Istres here right how does that stack up
against pet 20 the Zen of Python simple
is better than complex that is not a
simple system if the implementation is
hard to explain it's a bad idea like the
insides of JavaScript frameworks are
famously gnarly they are not easy to
explain here's a famous one there should
be one and preferably only one way to do
it
hoo-boy right so if the way we do web
development is a mess how should we do
it well this is what we do we take all
of these nasty frameworks and we replace
them all with Python so what we have is
a visual UI builder where you can drag
and drop components and you represent
them as Python objects a client-side
code in the browser is written in Python
we translate that into JavaScript so you
can just access your you are you don't
need to generate source code in a
different programming language you
represent your UI as objects Python on
the server of course but if you have
Python on the server and Python on the
client there's no reason to mash
everything into jason just to get it
from ones or the other no it's just a
function call we even have a Java Script
sorry
Python native database so that you can
access the database of rows and tables
as Python objects so you can take a row
from the database all the way from the
database to the visual UI without having
to change its representation and that is
very powerful all right so that's the
idea of how it works let me show you
what it looks like in practice okay
let's switch over so here I am in the
anvil editor I'm just going to show you
start by building like a simple hello
world app so I'm creating a new app I've
chose from a visual theme this here is a
web page and over here is a toolbox of
things I can put onto that web page so
I'm going to put a title on by dragging
a label which is a component that
displays some text up into the title I
can then edit its properties I can say
its text should be hello world and
that's how I put some text onto my page
all right let's do something more
exciting I'm going to put a card on here
I'm going to put so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna have an app where the
user enters their name and we display a
personalized greeting so I'm going to
add an input box so that it can answer
that question and a and we're going to
give us a name
this text box or we're going to call
name box everything in and roll has a
name so we can access it from code we've
got to have a button in here to click
when they're done nope nope not there in
here okay okay say hello and we can make
it a bit more prominent and you can see
what's going to happen right they're
going to enter their name click a button
a message is going to appear so that our
last thing is going to be a label for
that message to appear on I'm going to
call it message label because I lack all
creativity and we can say this is going
to be centered and make the font size
big and so so we've just built a webpage
and that's an awful lot faster than you
could have done it in HTML and CSS
the really cool thing is that every part
of this is backed by Python so if I
double click this button I'm editing the
Python code that runs when that button
gets clicked and you can see all the
things I dragged and dropped onto the
screen are available as variables in my
Python code so if I want to change the
text on that message label based on the
text that's been entered in the name box
I go self taught message label dot text
hello name box top text that's it okay
so so we've just built a web application
in a very short period of time in fact
it's already live online let me try
pointing this slightly walked more
towards myself it's already live online
this is its URL this is like one of
those Google Docs URLs so if you don't
have the URL you can't access it but I
can set it as public hello Pyke con sk
okay you could go - hello - PyCon SK
door and model app on your phone or your
computer right now and that app is live
we have built and published a web app in
actually the timer stop someone could be
someone could start that iPad screen
again I don't know exactly how long but
it was not long okay so that's fine but
this all happens in the browser remember
this Python actually gets compiled to
JavaScript and runs on the web browser
and any serious application is going to
need some server-side code as well so
what do we do well we can add further
modules and this is an ordinary Python
module that happens to run on our server
ordinary Python module ordinary Python
function takes a name parameter nope I
can't spell
can people read that hands up if you
can't read it okay that's a okay okay
so what we do there's an Audrey Python
function but we tagged this anvil dot
server horrible and we say so this says
this function on the server we should be
able to call it from the browser so if
we go back to our client side code as
well as updating the UI we go anvil dot
server call hmm we call this a hello
function we it has a parameter name so
we pass in the text from this name box
and now if we run this that I enter my
name you can see we've got something in
the app in the output in the log file so
now we've got some code running on the
server being driven by this Python user
interface we've built and sure this is
kind of limited right there's only so
much we can compile to JavaScript you
know you can't open files and so on but
this is a real pipe I'm sorry this is a
real C pipe in 3.7 running on the server
and you know it's got the full set you
know you want to do sax a database input
PI MySQL import PI [ __ ] Connect go I
want to do some numerical processing
import numpy I want to plot a graph
import matplotlib it's batteries
included in practice the first thing
everybody asks is how do I access a
database so we actually have a database
built-in you don't have to use it but
you can this is backed by Postgres so
this is not a toy you can put terabytes
into this thing if you want to so today
I'm going to do something slightly less
exciting I'm just going to store all the
names that get entered so we'll want a
text column for the name and we'll want
a date and date/time column for when it
was they signed up and we that's it I've
designed our database
this table is apt tables got visitors so
it's accessible from our code in exactly
the same way as those text box
and buttons were so if I go into sir the
code as well as updating printing this
into the log file we can take app tables
visitors and we can add a row to it we
fill out the name column with the name
that's been passed in we fill out the
win column with date time block now I'm
going to import that and now if we run
this we go to the database you can see
we've just so we've just built and
published remember this is online you
could use this from your phone now we
have built and published a database
backed web application in Python in a
very very short space of time I'm going
to show you one more thing before we get
on to showing you how it works
underneath which is how you display data
back from the database so remember we
could just return rows from this
database all the way to the clients so
if we want to display a table of who's
enter their name before we just make a
callable function get visitors oh and we
have it returned app tables drop
visitors search which is if we don't try
any query it's going to return
everything and then if we go back to the
UI go back to our design I'm going to
add a data table here data grid and it's
going to have one column for the name
it's gonna pull the name column out to
get a cover column for when entered key
is going to win and we don't need the
third column we can adjust these and so
on okay so in this grid is something
called a repeating panel and repeating
panel is a neat component that is got
the property called items and you've
give that anything you can iterate over
in Python and once you set the items it
will repeat this template for every
element in that list
so here in the init method we set we can
set the repeating pals
items to the return value of the get
visitors function and now we're
displaying data from our database on our
page simple as that
one last thing this dates kind of ugly
right we're taking a stir of a date time
and that does not look good
we'd like to you know to format that
date nicely so we go and we edit the
template and instead of the default
thing for that column we put a label in
here and then we set the data bindings
this is of course just a Python
expression so self dot item is a row
from the visitor table that is our
database row it's been passed all the
way from the server to the client we can
just pull out the win column and of
course that's a date time so we can
score the standard Python library
functions so if we run this now we
forward to the date and excellent Oh
someone's been trying our Unicode
support Bravo to you so you can see I
just built and shipped the database back
web app in a very short period of time
and you've used it so you know I am not
lying so let's see if the remote mics
working I'm now going to talk a little
bit about how that works behind the
scenes so if someone got past my water
bottle that'll be great so I'm gonna
talk it's just a set of mini tech talks
about how parts of anvil work underneath
thank you I'm going to top with
compiling Python to JavaScript because
this is obviously one of the major
things if you want to write your full
stack application with nothing but
Python then you're going to need to run
code in the browser and if you're
running code in the browser it has to be
in JavaScript so we need to somehow
translate Python to JavaScript
thankfully there's an open source
compiler called sculpt it's a Python
JavaScript compiler
and it does what you'd expect you feed
it a Python expression and it will
produce a JavaScript expression that
does the same thing you feed it a Python
function and it will produce honestly it
will produce the ugliest JavaScript
function you have ever seen but it will
do what that Python function does and
this is great but there is one problem
javascript in its infinite wisdom is a
100% non blocking language right you
cannot block partway through a function
to go you know check a database or fetch
something from the web and you know
you've seen me doing blocking operations
right I've made calls to the server and
then just use the return value I haven't
used I had to use callbacks and that's
something we'd like right give it more
concrete example you know here's here is
an API you might easily write in Python
right you get something from a database
and then you perform some computation on
it here is what that looks like in
JavaScript I count one two three nested
callbacks and in case somebody thinks
I'm being unfair to JavaScript here this
was copied and pasted from the first
page of the Postgres javascript
documentation but we have a Python
JavaScript compiler so we could
translate that into that automatically
right so let's get clone and get going
it turns out that sculpt has a classic
compiler architecture based
unsurprisingly on C Python so what you
do is you take a a Python expression or
module you then it then breaks it up
into bits of text that correspond to
sensible units in Python these by the
way these javascript file names that's
the source within the scope compiler if
you want to follow along at home and
then it assembles this into an abstract
syntax tree which is a tree of
operations that represent you know
things that we would make we would think
makes sense in Python so you know here
it's an assignment we are the thing
we're assigning to is a variable called
results the thing we the value we are
assigning it from is you know
action call we're calling the function
called F and we're passing these
arguments or so and then there's a
compiler that walks over this tree
emitting JavaScript so it's pretty clear
that this is the thing that we're going
to have to modify if we want to support
blocking execution so remember that this
compiler has to produce a JavaScript
function for every Python function which
means that it has to return so what we
do is we invent a new return type and we
say that if the JavaScript function
returns something of this type then it's
it's saying I've returned but I'm not
done yet I've just blocked and we call
this as type a suspension and so what we
do is how we compile this call is we
make the call and then we check is the
response a suspension if this response
is a suspension then we save all our
temporary variables we save all our
local variables we save where we are in
the function we've wrapped that all up
in a suspension of our own and then we
return that so here's that here's how
that looks at a slightly more real-world
example so we've got this button
one-click function it's calling get
which is calling into the database and
the database is blocked it's you know it
has to go back and get some data
so get realize it's been given a
suspension it saves its local saves its
variable saves its temporaries it saves
where it is in the function and then it
returns that as a new suspension that
wraps the inner one button one click
again the generated code realizes it's
been given a suspension so it saves its
locals it saves its temporaries and it
returns a suspension of its own and then
the JavaScript sits on it because we've
finished executing of course a full a
few milliseconds later the database
comes back and says got your data and so
the Java Script resumes that suspension
which jumps to the right place and the
function restores all the locals
restores all the temporaries and then
resumes the suspension which jumps the
right place in get the stall sorts
locals restore sorts temporaries calls
into to resume the database call which
of course returns immediately with the
data and now we're back to normal
execution and that's how we turn
blocking Python into non blocking
JavaScript yes scope talk is the website
we are always looking for
contributors I'm one of the maintainer
x' please do get in touch if you want to
join in here's another thing you saw me
doing out there I was making these calls
from client to server right just
managing to skip you know it an ordinary
web app that would be like routing and
rest endpoints and Jason mashing here
it's just a call we go Anvil's server up
call we give it a function name and we
give it some arguments it's a Python
call you've got positional arguments
we've got keyword arguments we've got
return values and well how do we do that
so it's blocking so it uses suspensions
obviously if you're on in the browser we
what we actually do is we do a remote
procedure call over WebSockets
and you know we encode the arguments the
return values as JSON which is fine for
the thing the values you see there right
these are all jace normal values but
what about values that aren't jason'll
right
you saw me throwing database rows around
they're just you know like they were
ordinary return values from a function
this is obviously something we want to
do and the question is how do we do it
and yeah okay just another illustration
ooh we have something in the database we
want to get things out of that database
and we want to be able to return those
values all the way back to the clients
as simple return values so the way we do
this is we have a concept we call live
objects which is this is a type of data
that you can pass to and from these
server functions and the important
things about live objects is that they
represent a server-side resource so you
know any client-side State is just cash
right that object is the database right
I have to be secure because just because
we're allowing the client code to call
methods on a database row doesn't mean
that the client code should be able to
call methods on any database row
otherwise every date of every visitor
has access to our whole database which
isn't exactly what we wanted so what we
do is we adopt the rule that possession
is permission so this is in compute
to science we call this a capability
model the idea is that if I've been
given the object then I have access to
the object so if I've returned that
object from a server function to the
client that was me giving permission to
the client code to access it and what
this means is you don't have to manage
your permissions separately from passing
these objects around so this is how it's
actually implemented so every live
object has an identifier you know this
is this table this row it's got some
methods we can call on it you know
updates delete a get item which is yeah
lets you access things of square
brackets set item and so on and of
course a set of permissions in this case
read-only and then what we do is we take
a digital signature over the whole life
object with a key that is known only to
the server and so every time we send a
live object of the client it's signed
and when the client passes a live object
back to the server then we can check the
signature and if the signature matches
then we know that must have been an
object we gave it because you know if it
didn't come from us the signature
wouldn't be right it's not for non for
chable we say and so this means that we
can safely put the give these things
that client have them pass back and
trust what the client is giving us so
here's what the API ends up looking like
so this is a simple server function you
know we're looking for a person with a
given name we check whether we are
logged in using the anvil built-in user
authentication system I don't have time
to show you but it's awesome and we
return a we get a row from the database
and we return that only if the users
logged in and of course on the client
that means we can just call the get
person function we get this database row
and we can call methods in this case get
item on that row again right the server
has chosen whether to return it with
that if statement so we've applied
security but that's the only you know we
didn't need to do permissions separately
we just chose whether to give you that
object we can of course be more clever
than this we can set permissions so we
don't have to be read-only all the time
this function returns a writable version
that days base rate so it takes the
people at tabletop people table it takes
a client writable version of that table
and then it searches that and so the
rows you get from that are going to be
client writable and so if you get this
in the client you can get this person
value and you can just increment its age
so this means that we can edit the
database from the browser from we can
edit the database from the code that
handled button clicks in a traditional
web application every operation you want
to perform you need to implement it at
every one of those five layers sorry six
layers even and here we can just do it
from our button click handler that's
going to save you a lot of work we can
get even cleverer still we can turn
views on tables because of course data
tables are live objects too so here's an
example we so we get the current user if
we are logged in we get a client
writable view of the records table but
only of the rows where the owner is the
current user and what that returns is
something we can use like a data table
right we can get this records object out
we can add rows we can search it we can
delete things but we can only add rows
with that value in the owner column and
we can only search rows with that value
in the owner column
so we've just delegated a whole chunk of
our database to client code for it to
operate on directly and there's a huge
number of operations we just don't even
have to write server things for and
again it's because we've got this
capability model that lets us delegate
permission to the place where it's most
convenient to write the code rather than
writing the code where it's most
convenient for the framework ok I'm
going to finish by talking about frankly
this is my favorite little mini Tech
Talk in about an Ville this is about the
autocomplete oh so you saw
I was typing in that demo there it was
code completing everything I wrote and
this is really really important right
auto completion is great hang on hands
up here who uses something like PyCharm
okay hands up here who are the Emacs and
vim diehards Hey okay a few of you right
so so I'm mostly preaching to the choir
here but I will say it autocomplete is
great
autocomplete is great because it gives
you discoverability it lets you discover
what's in an API without having to check
the documentation every time it gives
you speed because you can hit three
letters and hit the tab key it gives you
confidence to what you're doing is right
because there are whole classes of bugs
that you can eliminate without you work
even hitting the run button because the
autocomplete er has warned you that you
know that's not how you spell that word
or you know this variable wasn't the
type you expected it to be and for all
those reasons it feels good to use
confession we originally built anvil
without autocomplete we thought we could
get away without it I'm here to tell you
we were wrong autocomplete is essential
and if you are one of those diehards who
put your hand up and you're still using
Emacs or vim or something that doesn't
have autocomplete
I beg you get Jedi as a plug-in or any
of the similar plugins you can get just
do if you remember nothing else from
this talk do me a favor try it for a
week it will change your life
unfortunately for us these off-the-shelf
autocomplete errs weren't quite
sufficient couple of reasons one is of
course that anvils full stack so we need
your order completed to know about your
database and know about your server code
and know about your client code know
about we know what things you've dragged
and dropped on to that editor which I
mean you know we could have patched that
in but the real issue is that anvil is
of course in the web browser and when
you're in the web browser and you're
hitting the tab key there is just not
enough time to go back to the server
parse all the parse all your code for
come up with order completions and send
them back so we ended up having to
implement our own in JavaScript so here
I am opening
a Python conference by talking about my
JavaScript project please don't throw
anything at me
conveniently of course in vegan this
would be a really daunting undertaking
except we've got a Python JavaScript
compiler lying around so you already
seen how we can use sculpt to turn a set
of Python module into an abstract syntax
tree and that's exactly what we do so
when you hit the tab key we replace your
cursor with a random symbol and then we
throw the whole thing into sculpt and it
comes out with an abstract syntax tree
and we can then recursively walk that
tree and keep a build up a
representation of all the variables that
are in scope at every point in your code
and then when we hit the name node
containing our magic cursor symbol we go
well what are all the variables in scope
we can offer those as our completions of
course we either variables aren't the
only thing we can complete right you saw
me when I was accessing the database ROS
right we're Auto completing you know the
items available in get item square
bracket lookups in fact there's a bunch
of this because here we're also
completing you know the attributes for
app tables that users not search where
we're working out you know what you what
types you get when you when you call
that function we're working out what
type you get when you iterate over that
result and then we're pulling out the
possible square bracket lookups speaking
of function calls of course you don't
just want to know what a function what
type of function returns right you want
to be able to order complete these
arguments as well and you want of course
we want to do it across server and
client which is another thing that
traditional web stuff can't do which is
why we're missing what a complete in the
world you know we had autocomplete in
the 1990s and now all these web
developers are doing without it because
they the environments can't work out
what the server's doing anyway here's an
example right we have a server function
call
say hello we're passing a dictionary
into it and we really want to be able to
autocomplete the arguments in this and
so how we do this is we actually when
we're parsing a module as well as
keeping as well as keeping the the
top-level scope of that module so that's
you know all the functions in classes
and so on that are defined we can you
know because we need that for because
that's what you get if you import that
module we also store all the outbound
calls so we store all the function calls
that module makes and that means that
when we pass that client module we store
that function call and when we're
passing the server module we go oh weird
that we're passing the say hello server
function we know what arguments that
gets called with and so we pull that out
drop it into the local scope where it
autocompletes we autocomplete an awful
lot about Python types and this leads to
a rather philosophical question about
what exactly a type is because you could
say oh well the type of a Python object
is its class but we all know pythons are
more dynamic language than that we can
you know you can dynamically add
attributes onto individual object
instances and even when two things are
the same class you haven't done
something like that I mean are these two
variables the same type we certainly
want to autocomplete them differently so
what we do is we actually say try to
forget about the class of these objects
we duck type or autocomplete them as far
as our autocomplete er is concerned
these two things are two different types
and they will be autocomplete separately
obviously they share a bunch of methods
but they are two different types so I
would like to oh you know what I am
going faster I thought I'm going to demo
the thing that I was really sorry I had
to miss out this is something called the
uplink and I'm doing this specially for
Yann who wanted to do something with
hardware so if you are right if you
write the server modules in Annville
you didn't notice I didn't have to run
anything I didn't have to set anything
up it all ran on are in our servers
which is great for getting something
running quickly but sometimes you want
to run your code somewhere else right
you might be doing a big machine
learning job you want to write on a
machine with you know 20 GPUs out there
in AWS or maybe you're working with
individual hardware so um we have a way
of doing that you can connect your
Python code running anywhere to anvil
and how we do this is something called
the uplink so this is a library you can
pip install anywhere in the world and if
you enable it for your app you get a
link key and if you call amble that
server connect with that key from
wherever your code is running your code
is part of the anvil app and you can do
all the things you just see me do in
server code you can do from wherever
your code is running you can make
callable functions you can access data
tables you can call other functions the
works so let's show it to you right we
want to this code so what I'm going to
do is I'm gonna fire a Python
interpreter but nope that was not what I
wanted to do try it again how I see
right so okay get into a virtual
environment pip install and Ville uplink
course it's already installed in this
environment let's start the Python
interpreter ooh
we're in Python 2 today ok fine whatever
so I've called amelotte server at
connect I've connected we authenticated
we are now part of this app I can define
a function
I'm calling it say hi okay so just a
symbol function that runs this running
on my machine to find it on this laptop
on this podium and now if I edit this
code when you click the button instead
of calling to say hello I call say hi
and I run this we've just run code on
this laptop from the cloud and anybody
else who's still got that app open on
their foot on their computers can make
something appear on my terminal right
now and of course you can use this you
know you can use this on a server
somewhere out there running beefy
compute jobs or you can use it on a
Raspberry Pi that's controlling your
curtains or controlling an industrial
process okay that was my indulgent side
side part so I shown you a few things
about anvil and how they work underneath
and before I stop and take questions I'd
like to finish by talking a little bit
about the why of anvil the design
philosophy that's guided everything I've
shown you so far today and there are two
big principles involved here the first
is that code is good we are telling a
computer what to do and in nearly a
century of working with computers
humanity that has found the best thing
we have is writing text in a programming
language you will periodically encounter
something that will say oh I can you
know you can write code or write apps
without writing any code and this is
nearly always a false promise you'll end
up with a system that you know won't
support all of what you need or worse
you will find yourself
in a you know tangled up in flowcharts
shaking your monitor yelling let me
write the blasted for loop and so we let
you write the blasted for loop get you
to the code as soon as possible even in
the UI designer do you remember right
back at the beginning when I was
building that table of previous visitors
and I was formatting the date for when
the user had signed I wasn't dragging
and dropping some Wibbly line from a
database no I wrote a Python expression
even in the visual designer and what
that meant of course was that I had all
the power of the full Python libraries
at my fingertips get you meter the code
code is good
the second big principle is that we need
to be accessible
I've already ranted a bit about how the
web isn't accessible but let's be clear
we need to be simple enough for novices
it is frankly a disgrace that the
greatest application delivery platform
on earth the web you need to learn five
different programming languages just to
get started that is not acceptable we
need to be simple enough for novices to
use but that's only half of
accessibility because to be properly
accessible you need to be simple enough
for novices and you need to be powerful
enough for seasoned professionals and
this is partially for the novices
benefit actually because if you say oh
here's something that's easy to use but
you're you know you're in the kiddie
section you're in the playpen then
you've stopped those people growing you
know you need to let them grow their
powers but also you know seasoned
professionals we need some love too
right just because I can write five
different programming languages doesn't
mean I want to and it certainly doesn't
mean that my boss wants to wait for me
to do it and you might look at this and
think yeah sure but these are
incompatible goals and I want to say
that that is wrong and it should be
obvious to everybody in this room that
that is wrong because Python does it
right the reason that we are all in this
room the Python programming
which is the first thing that you will
show an eight-year-old in their first
lesson with a Raspberry Pi and it's what
Instagram use and it's what google
deepmind use to beat the human brain at
the game of Go for the first time in
history Python shows us it is possible
in for something to be simple enough for
novices and powerful enough for seasoned
pros and it is only the garbage fire of
traditional web development that makes
us doubt it thank you very much
[Music]
I will before I go into questions I will
go for a beat brief plug if you're
interested in what you've seen and you
want to get hands-on with this we are
leaving a workshop at 1310 today in the
hall be I'm not gonna try to pronounce
that because I'm good a butcher the
Slovak my apologies but please do come
in and join and see what it's like to
actually use all right time to move on
to questions should I just read these
from mania if I'm going to do that those
are some fantastic words that it
concluded with you know why should we
learn five different programming
languages just to just to work on the
biggest platform and and and yeah it is
the Python is an excellent example of
showing something have been both simple
and powerful there are a couple of
questions that you have received them
one with the most up votes this appears
to be a proprietary closed framework
why would I rely on a non open source or
be the very exciting product seems very
risky try to convince me ah right ok so
the short version of this is that there
is a really great way to get a very very
full-featured open source framework and
that's to have a bunch of venture
capitalists fund a company try to build
something then make it open source try
to make some money out of it and as 99%
of them do fail don't get me wrong I
would love to open-source anvil if but
the market has busily shown us I used to
say that the market has been busy
showing us that there is room for
precisely one large open large
successful open source company and
that's read that Red Hat sponsors today
only even they got bought by IBM a few
weeks ago so it's it is very great to
have a look at docker right docker have
transformed their industry and there
they make they you know they haven't
made a profit they make basically no
revenue because their value ends up
getting captured by commercial offer
offerings on top so I would argue that
in fact it being a paid product and the
fact that we are in fact you know a
profitable startup means that is likely
to stay around longer than your average
VC funded open source project and you're
going
some kind of funny if you want to build
something this big this was not a small
undertaking can I do a follow-up here
have you considered taking other forms
of financing like grants like Jupiter
did or others as models that would make
these you know that will help you also
take off more and yes we have considered
it we have decided that they do not in
fact help as much as we think we did and
I don't want to get into like just spend
the rest of it okay the next one is it's
possible to run anvil on all the servers
or locally yes absolutely
it goes doctor doc and composed pol
docker compose up and then you have a
whole version of this running locally
there's also the intermediate step I
showed you the uplink you know if you
have something local you have a local
database that's sensitive but you want
to expose just like one or two queries
on it that's fine you can write an
uplink script that has a function that
will perform the one or two queries you
want to expose to your web app and keep
the rest of your data private but as I
say you know if you need all your data
on-site that's fine we have on-site
stuff come talk to me afterwards
fantastic what about the performance of
this approach that was asked at a
particular point during the during the
talk and I can't remember what exactly
was talking about so obviously compiling
Python to JavaScript is this is less
fast than writing it directly in
JavaScript we take sculpt takes this hit
to provide a better Python emulation
right you saw when I was compiling that
string object it was a sculpt built in
string object I wasn't using JavaScript
strings that is so that we can preserve
the Python semantics in practice
execution speed of the stuff that's
running in the web browser is not
usually our limiting factor ultimately
of course we're either in the long term
once we're still waiting for a couple
more things the browser in the long term
sculpt is probably going to shift to
targeting webassembly at which point it
will be plenty fast of course on the
server side if that's what you're asking
about it's just C Python right it's got
all your standard extensions it runs
like greased lightning who's her target
goog who's this product meant for we
have some larger examples of animal
being used in production
yes we do have examples no I can't talk
about them in front of a crowded
audience I am really you cannot I can't
tell you how frustrated I am that I
cannot drop some names here yeah so it's
difficult to say who's it meant for
because of course a programming tool by
its nature is widely usable right we
have people using an anvil everybody
everywhere from schools using the free
version we have everything I've seen me
do in today's demo can be done on the
free version so the schools using very
capable free version there's hobbyists
there's individuals working on a work
building their own projects people
building startups people who have built
startups on anvil and now have you have
millions of dollars in the team of
people and there are big companies using
internal tools built using its building
internal tools can't use an example of
video and truly huge companies who are
sufficiently paranoid that they need the
on-premise installation yes there are
big companies I'm sorry I cannot name
especially while that video cameras
running I really take up a couple more
but yeah sure cool we still have four
minutes you said that you are converting
Python code to Jas is there's also some
kind of magic you mentioned before is a
bad approach so okay so I specifically
qualified as the wrong kind of magic and
the wrong kind of magic is something
like an ORM is a really good example of
this although JavaScript frameworks do
the same thing the thing that makes that
magic dangerous is that it abuses the
semantics of the layer you're working on
to represent an adjacent layer right you
that book top price that less than 20
was not a numerical calculation and if
you try to think about it like a Python
programmer you are going to come unstuck
fundamentally if you want to use
something like SQL alchemy in production
you're going to have to understand
Python and understand SQL and understand
how SQL alchemy does the translation it
is a very very leaky abstraction this is
not true of a compiler right I do not
need to understand how
see Python works to write Python I do
not need to understand how sculpt works
to write Python I do not need to
understand JavaScript to use anvil and
so this is a kind of abstraction we will
stand behind can you give some example
of a real website built by anvil or
maybe a couple of websites Pun maybe a
couple of websites so there are some out
there again I'm really annoyed because
obviously a lot of the biggest project
here are internal tools of that of
companies that I can't show you even
though they are really cool there's a
there's a startup called lightning AI
which have given us permission to to use
their names they have like an ad tech
serving platform actually they're a
perfect example it was you know a data
scientist a Python astir with it you
know maths masters who need wanted to
build an app tech product she had the
statistics that was her yeah that was
her thing she didn't have the full full
stack web capability it was going to
cost her what the best part of a hundred
thousand dollars to get someone to build
just the first prototype and everybody
knows the first prototype is not what
you're actually going to want to ship
instead of which she grabbed this and
built it herself
lightning AI is the thing to Google if
you want to find them there's more than
a dozen more questions so yeah let me
know when I run out of time okay if
you'd like to continue there's there's
more questions which is kind of hard to
understand can you show us the quiet
resource of that example so by the way
if I may when you write like things like
that example is useful if you if you
refer to a specific example so that yeah
I don't know which example you're
talking about so I'm going to show you
something generic come find me
afterwards if there was something you
meant something else so a really
important thing about anvil and the
reason that the things that make it C
powerful of the seasoned professionals
is there's always an escape hatch to the
low-level high power tool right one
example of this I didn't talk about is
version control right every anvil app is
a git repository I can't check this out
with git and work with it on my local
machine it is property version control
and another of the these escape hatches
that
let you use the power tools is that you
can drop down and edit HTML and
JavaScript and CSS so here's an example
I'm gonna go into the assets of my page
I'm going to edit the HTML now the
crucial thing here is that we are not
editing the HTML that comes out of anvil
we are editing the HTML that goes in and
what that means is that when I make a
change here I have not broken my
abstraction I can edit this HTML and
then go back into the drag-and-drop
designer and I can still use it you know
you don't offer them the choice between
easy for novices and powerful for
seasoned pro you offer them both at the
same time so you saw when I started up I
chose like my visual theme and I chose
like a Google material design theme this
is the HTML and the CSS that implements
that theme and I can go in and I can
edit it if you go onto our user forums
you can find lots of examples of people
editing it to their satisfaction or
creating like a you know company house
style but again anything you edit here
will show up in the designer and you can
still use the power tools alongside the
easy-to-use stuff ok fantastic so let's
give a hand to bear it
[Music]